i will never forget what you did at
valoma
you think she didn't spiral because of
you you didn't add to that and now
you're trying to do it to nicole
mind game
i never tried to hurt her
i never tried to hurt paloma i never
tried to
hurt any of the girls in the house
big brother season 24 contestant daniel
durston brings taylor hale to tears and
now fans are raging the new people to
fall in love with new showmances to see
blossom new people to root
maybe against you know a new like
favorite villain we always say expect
the unexpected and that is the beauty of
this show and that couldn't be truer on
wednesday's episode here's how it went
down nicole layog was feeling emotional
about the game so taylor comforted her
festy bestie the two are coupled in the
show's latest twist all i'm gonna say is
whatever you need to do at any point do
what's best for you okay
[Music]
um
i appreciate you saying that if there's
a point where
you gotta tap out of the fight
don't even
that's not even part of my vocabulary
but to nicole it felt like a passive
aggressive attack
she was like
you know gosh if you decide that you
want to quit
and stop fighting
it's
okay oh beautiful i'm with her i will
not talk to her from here now yeah that
didn't sit well with daniel and he lost
his cool
no with your fake
[Music]
i am a face don't speak to me until
finale
you're bringing me to finale no when
you're sitting out there
this guy hates me
the same you did a paloma you're trying
to do to her
you can [ __ ] right off you don't think
america's watching all that
and get this daniel also blamed taylor
for paloma aguilar leaving earlier this
season she exited the game to protect
her mental health
you think she didn't spiral because of
you you didn't add to that and now
you're trying to do it to nicole
mind game
that's not fair
that's really do not speak to nicole
like that ever again what ever again
not trying to hurt or manipulate anybody
and um it seems like every time i try to
connect with somebody
i'm just hurting
even when taylor tried apologizing to
nicole she was coldly shut down you need
to learn how to speak to people
what you said to me was
very passive aggressive
and very rude
personally i have never once witnessed a
concrete instance in which taylor
bluntly disrespected somebody it makes
me feel bad she doesn't deserve it
now fans on social media are making
their thoughts loud and clear one fan
says the way many people in the house
have treated taylor is absolutely
unacceptable but daniel has reached a
different level of cruelty while another
tweeted daniel durston and nicole layog
are the worst big brother house guests
i've ever seen their treatment of taylor
hale has been so disgusting to witness
and interestingly when et spoke with
daniel ahead of the season he said his
top goal is making friends i hope to
gain from big brother is truly lifelong
friendships even after they hate me in
the house even after i evict them i do
hope when the dust settles that we all
have this great bond together in the end
taylor was supported by some house
guests who invited her to join an
alliance against those trying to get her
out i guess what julie says is true
expect the unexpected and you can expect
to see a lot more of me
[Music]
you